[Music]
christina is in new york city hi
christina welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um so my question is i
own property i'm contributing to my
retirement
and i have about 150 000 saved in like a
growth money market account
so i'm just not really sure like should
i just keep that money in that account
and just keep you now putting into it
should i invest it in some way i just
want to make sure like i'm doing like
the responsible thing how soon are you
wanting to use that money maximizing
how soon are you wanting to use that
money is this a one to two year is this
five
years or more
you say again how soon will you need the
money
uh well i i don't i don't like need it
like for anything i'm just i'm just
saving okay you just want to grow are
you out of debt 100
yes no mortgage no i mean i don't want
to say i'm out of debt i mean i own my
house so no mortgages
no i have a mortgage
okay how much is your mortgage
um like 3 500 a month no baby the
balance
oh well i just sold my condo and just
bought a house with my fiance so the
balance right now that we always like
650.
okay
you bought a house with your fiance
yes
and when is the marriage taking place
uh next year
okay
all right you're in a very precarious
and dangerous situation until you're if
you're not going to get married soon you
guys need to get some written
documentation
immediately
on this house
okay
if something goes sideways horrible in
your all's lives this house is going to
be a major problem if it happens before
marriage
okay you can you tell you're talking to
a guy who's seen cancer before and i
know what cancer looks like
yeah
okay
so you didn't even think of all these
things bad things that could happen but
for 30 years i've been doing this with
people that have had all the bad things
happen
okay
so something bad happens in the
relationship you're suddenly a partner
with your former fiance
in a house
that needs some written partnership
documentation
and partnership documentation deals with
the d's death disability drug use
default
divorce
which can't happen here but it could be
called uh i saw him on facebook with
another girl or something like i don't
know i don't think it's gonna happen to
you i doubt it's gonna happen to you but
you need all this written down kiddo i
don't want you being one of our
customers for the wrong reasons okay
because you just scared me to death when
you said that now
having said all of that does your fiance
have any money
um
yeah he does
cash
uh in the bank yeah how much
um probably ten
okay so you're the rich one
okay you're the saver he's the spender
okay and what does he make a year
uh 130 000. great cool and what do you
make a year
the same good excellent so you got a 260
000 combined income
um when you do get it combined by
marriage
let's see here
does he have debt other than this house
no
none
not a student loan not a car payment not
nothing
uh well he does have a car payment i
think but i mean i think it's going to
be paid off what do you think debt is
it's gotta be paid off in a year
okay
i actually give you any debt no do you
have a mortgage yes does your other
balance have any debt no does he have a
car payment yes
i have a car payment oh you have a car
payment goodness gracious
is there any other non-debt that you
have that's debt
no that's it just the mortgage and the
car payments
okay what's the car loan balance
um
i'm i mean i just signed a lease so
okay
i would call the i would call the lease
company and ask what the early buyout is
lisa's basically financing a car and i
would write a check today you're not
gonna do any of this but i'm gonna tell
you what you should do okay
and i would pay off your car today he
should start working to get his paid off
as soon as he possibly can you said he
was on plan to do it inside of a year
okay that's number two number one
suggestions pay yourself number two
suggestions he needs to pay his off
don't pay off his car until you're
married the faster you guys can actually
get married the faster you're going to
solve all the financial and legal mumbo
jumbo that you're getting into because
it's very difficult for you to work
together and be protected against bad
situations until you're married
so the faster you're married i know it's
not romantic and it wasn't your plan but
the faster you're married the more you
solve the issues under new york law with
the house ownership
and with the
you know because you could reach over
today
and i would suggest this and george
would suggest this and throw the 150 at
the house and start reducing the house
because that's our next step is get your
house paid off once your cars are paid
off but i don't want you paying off a
house that you're in joint ownership
with a broke person on
okay
and right now you're a partner with a
broke person now that's a financial
analysis it's not saying your your
fiance is a deadbeat or something like
that but he has 10 grand you have 150
grand
you both make 130 okay you know if so
let me tell you what happened one time
this is not gonna happen to you
but this is why i'm freaking out so
you'll understand i'm not just a weirdo
okay
i had a lady in the exact same situation
you're in the the fiance gets killed in
a car wreck now she owns the house with
his parents
yeah that was what i was told actually
happens like yeah that's exactly what
does happen unless there's a will
so there needs to be a will in place
today with the partnership agreement so
that you get the entire freaking house
if something happens he gets the entire
freaking house or something happens okay
and that's what that's why i'm freaking
out here i don't think that's gonna
happen what are the percentage chances
of that nothing probably but this is
what you've opened yourself up to
by engaging in what felt like the right
thing to do because your relationship is
strong okay and i'm not saying he's a
bad guy or you're a bad girl i'm not
saying any of that i'm just saying
you're just open to that and it scares
me for you
so i want you to protect yourself and
the sooner you get married the less soon
you have to do all that so if you run
down and get married this weekend and
then have the celebration in a year
then legally you're fine
you have to worry about anymore if you
did that then i'm going to pay off both
cars immediately out of your 150 and
throw the rest at the house wouldn't you
absolutely but
we got to do some things in order here
and there's a lot of mortgage here and
the car payments and it makes me sick to
my stomach yeah but you got 260 000
income assuming you're married
that's cool i mean you're making a
freaking quarter of a million dollars
even in new york city that's a lot of
money
so hey hang on we're going to put you
guys through financial peace university
as our wedding gift because i think the
wedding is pending
dave just sped up the process you think
i might have dialed it up i don't i
doubt it i doubt i had any impact at all
but it's fun to try this is the ramsey
show